[Music]
Captain Marvel is currently doing the
rounds at exclusive fan screenings and
press events and whilst there's been no
official posts from those involved in
the media several outlets have leaked
the entire plot of the movie the leak
was initially posted on 4chan and though
some said it was fake it actually
matches exactly with the plot of the
novelization and that is being released
alongside the movie but even cool
recently matched the stories and whilst
I'm not a fan of dealing purely in
speculation I think this seems pretty
accurate throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the plot as well as how it
leads into the greater MCU I've edited
certain parts so they read better so
this isn't completely verbatim there
will of course be nothing but spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything then I highly suggest that you
turn off now with that out the way I'm
definition and welcome to the channel
where I roon it so you don't have to
carol danvers is a pilot that during an
excursion is ambushed by a scrawled
spaceship during which she is caught in
the explosion of a stolen Creed of ice
that gives her superpowers Star Force
Commander Yan rogue played by Jude Law
rescues her and takes her to the Kree
homeworld hala here she is brainwashed
into believing she is a free warrior and
recruited into Star Force during a
mission star forces ambushed by the
scrolls and all book Carol are killed
Carol is captured by the scrolls but she
blows up airship and escapes she a fleur
kin named goose who eventually
transforms into goose the care due to
their shape-shifting abilities and all
remaining scrolls crush on earth tell us
and his group infiltrate shield and plan
to use earth's resources and attempt to
capture her at this point
Carol meets Fury and Coulson after he
mistakenly thought she was about to
steal from him that's when Carol the
Texas scrolls by with him she kills this
scroll and then goes on the run Fury
returns to shield with the body of the
dead scroll he has a bad feeling about
his other colleagues and so decides to
meet Carol and lead her to a secret
shield base where info about her is
stored Carol remembers her life on earth
in
Unite's with her best friend Maria and
her daughter Monica
the three learned the tesseract is being
kept in a secret Space Station and go to
retrieve it kidnapping a scroll who
followed them and his ship the group
manages to retrieve the cube well get
ambushed by Talos and his soldiers Carol
sends fury and Monica back to earth
before Ronan arrives he explains that
the Kree and the scroll Empire have
separately made a deal with a tyrant
named anos to give him the cube and
other gems in exchange for help in their
war he argues that whoever has the cube
will turn the direction of the conflict
revealing also that the Skrull spaceship
that ambushed her years ago was actually
a Kree one Carol breaks free and attacks
both sides until young rogue appears
Carol finds out yon Wragge a super
Skrull the really on rug was lured into
a trap on earth and assassinated so a
scroll spy could take his place
Carol was testing a tesseract powered
spacecraft and stumbled upon the ambush
the Kree device merged her DNA to the
tesseract which is why she's so powerful
scroll rogue then decided to shape into
the perfect soldier so the scrolls could
lay a brain washer and use their as a
weapon
angry at this Carol Titor out with
squirrel rogue but being a super scroll
he can easily copy her abilities she
remembers why she became an Air Force
member and vaporizes rock she leaves
fury in charge of protecting the
tesseract and Earth before forcing the
Kree and Skrulls into a peace treaty
Ronan refuses to accept this angles
rogue which leads into the events of
guardians of the galaxy Carol gives fury
a pager in case of emergencies and
leaves to become a one-woman defense
against intergalactic war other things
to know are the Star Force suit can
change colors
it starts out green and black and when
Carol regains her memories have been an
American soldier she switches it to red
and fury doesn't lose his eye and
Coulson gets injured during the train
chase and doesn't appear again until the
annette bening is carol's dead mother
the Kree supreme intelligence uses her
appearance to communicate with Carol
keroth is the only survivor of the
scroll ambush on Star Force but he gets
badly injured requiring the cybernetic
implants that he has in guardians of the
galaxy and that concludes everything we
know so far about the movie's main plot
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it and if you're still going to see
it I've got my ticket for Friday and
we'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the movie am I
soon to come ending explain video once
I've watched the film I've also created
a separate video about post-credit
scenes and what happens in them it could
be linked after this one this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]